that's I think that's the best
introduction I've had so far I guess I
said that on record Oh
okay but uh thank thank everyone for
coming so I'm not not quite talking
about crowdsourcing today but really
what I want to share with you today is
how I've worked to align my work with my
values and my hopes for the world okay
but my hope for this talk is not so much
that you walk out of here with my values
but instead that you're inspired to
think a bit more about your own values
how how to realize them out in the world
and I think that'd be really wonderful
if that's the outcome of this talk so
with that I'd like to share with you
some thoughts on computational
ecosystems and what I think they can do
for advancing human values at scale so I
want to start by just noting this
question that as I started learning more
about my work what I realized is that
all these challenges and questions I was
interested in essentially came down to
this question how can we create scalable
solutions to human problems and advance
desire human values in the absence of a
technology that can overcome real-world
constraints okay so as a computer
scientist and as a technologist like
many of you are this is a really
unfortunate question for me to be asking
right but it's just the question that
kept coming up okay so let me start by
giving you an example when I first got
to Northwestern I began mentoring
undergraduate students in research ok
and this photo is taken from spring 2014
I started a program called design
technology and research and we started
with just seven students but in about
two years I was mentoring over 20
students in 14 independent research
projects and very quickly I learned that
faculty time doesn't scale okay like you
can't you could kind of stretch it a
little bit but not really right I mean
there's a fixed number of hours in the
day
so the general challenge then is how can
a single faculty mentor train 20-plus
students right this is the part about
scaling the solution to this problem
to cultivate autonomous self-directed
learners right so people who are going
to do independent work and build new
knowledge for science right these are
the values that I cared about in this
project but in the absence of a
technology that scales my time
okay and this is the real world
constraint you know like I said can't
really stretch it so as we started
thinking about this problem we realized
that it's actually really hard and the
reason it's really hard is that the best
human solution which is awesome it
doesn't scale very well okay and the
best human solution we know is called a
printer ship or 101 mentoring as you're
familiar with and it's a highly
effective model for training people to
do complex tasks but as alan collins
reminds us and alan collins kind of like
the Godfather of cognitive
apprenticeship which is apprenticeship
of the mind for skills like research
he says the sadly apprenticeship
requires a very small teacher to learn a
ratio that's just not realistic in the
large educational systems of modern
economies and we might think that like
some other problems there'd be a good
machine solution but here it's really
not clear that there's a best machine
solution in sight so software can be
used to provide helpful prompts to guys
student thinking but no AI technology
can replace the mentor in the
foreseeable future right and one of the
ways to think about that is that to have
an AI to do this you really want a model
of how to solve complex ill structure
problems as you would come commonly see
in design and in research and you will
want to have models of instruction for
teaching people how to do that right and
we have neither of those two things so
now if you think about what options we
have given this is kind of a state of
affairs we could wait for a
technological silver bullet right but it
could take quite a while or it might
never come you could imagine instead
compromising in a variety of way so
instead of scaling undergraduate
research you could try to scale lecture
right you could do MOOCs you could do
those kinds of things you could train a
small set of uni students right as we
typically do with PhD students or you
could give undergrads route work you
just say okay here's a project you know
here's some stuff to do and that's still
good right because you're getting
undergrad to involved in research yet
none of these options really provide the
same learning benefits and scale as the
values that I wanted to scale so over
the last five years this general
question has led us to the design of
what I call computational ecosystems
and what computational ecosystems are is
that their systems that inner weave
community process social structures and
intelligence systems to unite people and
machines to overcome these larger
challenges okay so as you can see from
this figure computational ecosystems
incorporate many different components
and the goal here is not just to concern
us with the design of components but
instead with the design of the entire
system and this focus on a systems
approach to design echos calls from
people like Atul Gawande
from the Harvard Medical School who
argues that in essence having great
components is not enough okay so here
Atul says we've been obsessed in
medicine with components we want the
best drugs the best technologies the
best specialists but we don't think too
much about how it all comes together
it's a terrible design strategy actually
and Atul goes on to say that making
systems work is the great task of our
generation of physicians and scientists
I would go further to say that making
systems work whether it's a healthcare
education climate change and making a
pathway out of poverty is the great task
of our generation as a whole we also see
this call for system level thinking in
artificial intelligence so here's Erik
Horvitz who's the director of Microsoft
Research and he says I'm pretty sure
that the next leaps in AI will come from
integrative systems rather than wedges
right so wedges being components or
wedges of intelligence he argues that we
need to focus on building a system where
the whole is greater than the parts and
closer to home in HCI there's been
similar calls for a need for system
level thinking so one such call comes
from George furnace who in this
wonderful paper called future design
mindful of the morass which all the
students should read if you're
interested in designing systems and he
says it's likely that our designs will
be more successful if we became more
mindful of the bigger picture the mosaic
of responsive adaptive systems right now
what he's referring to is that if we're
designing applications we need to think
about how those applications fit into
the larger systems that in which that
application operates okay now I think
would be really wise for all of us the
heat George's words
but as it turns out we need to do more
than just be mindful of the larger
system we actually need to design the
entire system for solving some of the
problems that I'm interested in so to
design this entire system we take a
socio-technical approach as you may
already be familiar with but we extend
it in variety of ways to account for the
added complexity of having to design the
whole system okay
so for example when designing a
socio-technical system we typically do
consider the context of the larger
system but in practice solutions are
often created component by component or
layer by layer okay so let me give you
some examples of that so for example we
might be thinking about supporting group
collaboration and focus on new
collaboration technologies for
supporting a group right or we might as
many people in the room and myself in
the past think about creating
technologies for coordinating crowds
okay and this is all great but one of
the things we're thinking about with
computational ecosystems as an approach
to design is that we're interested in
how to bring together multiple
structures of people and interactions to
jointly solve a problem that gives us
new synergies that can arrive when these
component interactions inform each other
to enable new kinds of solutions so as
another example you could consider
designing layer by layer okay so we
might first come up with a process of
working like this is how our group or
organization is going to work and then
we might design the social structures
for supporting that way of working and
then go on to design tools based on
those social structures and the process
of work right and this is actually a
very thoughtful approach to designing
technologies right because you're
considering things that are in place for
example in your organization and
especially of those processes as social
structures are things that you can't
change but what I was interested in is
thinking about are there opportunities
to design an entire vertical slice as
one right where there might be new
compositions of processes working with
the structure of social interactions and
technologies that kind of all work well
together and gives you very different
designs then if you assume certain
things to be fixed so in essence what
I'm saying is that with computational
ecosystems we're interested in designing
simultaneously all the components of a
socio technical system
as a single integrative solution okay so
we're still going to be thinking about
people and technology but we're gonna
take a more comprehensive approach where
we construct the parts but also how all
the parts interact together both
technically and people-wise as well and
to do this and to reason about the added
complexity of thinking about the whole
system we're gonna adopt two helpful
perspectives in our design work so one
of the ideas is computational thinking
just as you're already familiar with but
we're thinking about computational
thinking to decompose and distribute
problem-solving to humans and machines
who could best address them across the
entire ecosystem and the other idea is
something that I call ecological
thinking and the idea there is that we
want to create sustainable processes and
interactions that support both the
ecosystem members but furthermore
supports proper ecosystem function okay
so as I go through my talk and present
some examples of ecosystems you're gonna
see ideas from this kind of
computational thinking ecological
thinking throughout the examples so for
the rest of the talk I'm gonna present
two examples of computational ecosystems
one for community-based planning and
another one for scaling research
training and then I'm gonna preview
what's next in computational ecosystems
and now I'll just end with some thoughts
on what technology what the role of
technology is in advancing human values
ESCO okay so before I move on to my
first example any questions thus far
yeah
maybe you're gonna get that what does a
research contribution look like when
you're operating at that scale yes
let me start seeing that there's gonna
be some designs that look a little
different but give us new principles or
system level principles I would say for
design that's not just about how you
would design a single component but how
these pieces can work together yeah so
one way you could think about it is
almost like what's a design pattern for
systems right instead of for crowds or
for groups right yeah that's a great
question thanks any other questions
yeah yeah sure I mean let's let's go
with can i rephrase your question a
little bit so instead of computational
systems why don't you just call them
socio technical systems is that is that
fair okay great so there are social
technical systems right as I was saying
it's the approach to design that's
different right so instead of designing
component by component or layer by layer
as we might do in the past we're just
kind of thinking about how do you design
a system and what kind of advantages you
get when you start thinking about the
system as a whole okay and I hope the
examples that I present them will start
to say huh okay there's some things that
you could get that that's kind of really
hard to get when you just design a
component it's the approach to design
yeah
the process or their approach to design
right yeah what you'll see is the
socio-technical system it's a fairly
complicated one compared to a single
application socio-technical system that
you might see in some cases but yeah so
socio-technical system okay so do you
have a question yeah just briefly to
what extent and you might get to this so
if you are yeah what is that
in these systems to think about
adaptability or flexibility as far as
just being built in and is there a
trade-off between having an adaptability
you know with your question can we save
that one for the end of
I think you're right after you see the
examples of systems can become really
crucial or something that we might want
to think about a great great question I
like what your headset okay great so let
me let me move on and give you an
example of a computational ecosystem so
first I'd like to talk about
community-based planning where we're
trying to design an inclusive process
for planning community events that
scales and that advances the goal of its
members okay so some of you might seen
some of this work on COBE that I'm about
to present in the past right or various
components or pieces of it but I hope
seeing it as an ecosystem is going to
give you some new perspective and new
ways of thinking
so the subsist case that we're looking
at is planning large academic
conferences right and what I'm showing
you here is a handful of associate
chairs or ACS coming working together to
try to come up with a preliminary
schedule for for CAI and this is taken
in 2012 and what they're doing is
they're trying to construct hundreds of
sessions about 200 over a two-day period
on paper on the wall okay so that's the
test they were facing and immediately
you can see that these organizers face
some critical challenges okay so the
first one is that there's about I want
to say about 10 organizers that are in
the room and what you see is that they
lack information about what it is that
the whole community wants right and what
it is that the whole community know so
Kai's gotten I think it's probably
bigger than this now but even then it
was about 500 papers and it's became
pretty hard for any single person or any
ten people to really have a good
understanding of all the content right
so to even know what papers relate to
each other and will make for a good
session is something that's very
difficult to do at the small group much
less what all the preferences of all the
thousands of attendees who are attending
might be and furthermore the organizers
lack tools for managing the complexity
of the planning problem and also in
resolving conflicts okay so clearly
there are some challenges just working
on this with paper as the only tool that
they had available but what was even
more difficult is when the chairs go
home they put this schedule into a
computer and then they go through this
super painful and time-consuming process
as they're trying to resolve conflicts
where they try to resolve one conflict
right by moving a session to an
excuse me to another place but then you
have to swap right so another session
goes in its place and then you create
another conflict all right so you
resolve wine you create wine and what
they described it as is a terrible game
of whack-a-mole right where the Mo's are
conflicts so it's really unpleasant okay
and to overcome these challenges then we
created Kobe which is a computational
ecosystem for a new process that we call
community informed planning okay and
Kobe's belt on just two simple ideas one
engaged the entire community in the
planning process and the second one give
organizers tools to manage the
complexity of planning and resolve
conflicts right so these ideas are very
simple but the real question is how do
you do this right and that's where we're
gonna see some interesting ideas in
ecosystem thinking so let me start by
talking about engaging the whole
community in planning so to do this we
created new processes and tools for
involving committee members authors and
attendees so we engage committee members
to make the initial sessions right after
the PC meeting we ask authors to tell us
which papers fit well in a session with
their own paper but also what talks they
want to see so we make sure those talks
are not kind of opposing the session
that they're presenting their paper in
we then help attendees navigate the
schedule with a tool called comfor where
we are recommending papers and sessions
to people and as people favorite them
we're starting to identify what the
popular sessions are going to be um so
we could put them in bigger rooms and
then we also could identify talks of
mutual interest so if a lot of people
want to see this talk and that talk and
they're at the same time right you want
to move them so that they're not at the
same time okay um so so far this is
pretty straightforward right it's a
crowdsourcing kind of problem and we're
thinking about kind of designing for
each of these groups of people but right
off the bat there's actually some
computational challenges we need to
think about okay so if we just focus on
committee sourcing for a second and
think about the problem of making
sessions one of the things that you must
account for is thinking about how to
coordinate problem solving given that
there are global constraints okay so let
me just give you an example is if you
think about a paper write a paper could
often fit into many possible sessions
right not just one but here's the thing
if you collect a bunch of potential
sessions that's
not necessarily enough right because the
paper is only going to go to one and
once this paper goes into this session
oh the other potential sessions that had
those other papers those fall apart
right so you have to have to think about
the intent dependencies across these
sessions because you have these session
making constraints so to resolve this
challenge the first core idea I'm going
to present is using this two-phase
collaborative planning process that
involves both a large crowd of all the
ACS and a smaller group of about ten
aces okay so in phase one we're gonna
involve all the ACS to elicit metadata
or possible groupings of papers into
sessions okay and then in Phase two a
smaller group of ACS
were given all these flexible options
that were collected can deliberate and
discuss in a small group how to satisfy
the tighter constraints right which are
more difficult to do in a crowd so as
you're doing this in real time right you
might have 200 people kind of tagging
and going in at the same time to manage
this process we have a system cuff
frenzy led by Lydia Chilton and what it
does is it uses actionable feedback
which are these things on the left to
tell people what it is that still needs
work
right so it's just telling people hey
these are things still need to be tagged
these are things that still needs to be
put into sessions but what's interesting
about the system is that using the same
system by changing the actionable
feedback at different phases of problem
solving you can make it into a crowd
where system at first where a lot of
people are participating and then you're
just shifting the feedback you're giving
and then it becomes a group or system as
you might traditionally think about and
it supports small group working together
and deliberating and having these
discussions as well alright so so
there's just the example of how you can
move from a crowd to a group by
designing across so coming back to the
general challenge of engaging the
community for authors and attendees
we're gonna need ways to give them
relevant suggestions right of papers
that might be similar to theirs and then
for attendees of things they might want
to see and you could you could clearly
treat this as a machine problem right
and think about these as isolated
questions where here you might do some
TF idea for something like that and then
there you might do collaborative
filtering right and then you build up a
preference profile over time and that's
all very reasonable and you could
definitely do that
but you could do better than that if you
take a ecosystems kind of view on this
okay and the second core idea I'm going
to present to you is this idea I call
incentive chaining okay and the idea
behind incentive chaining is that we're
going to try to engage increasing sets
of ecosystem members by using the data
collected in an earlier interaction and
seeding it to get further contributions
from subsequent interactions and making
that better okay so for example what we
do here is that we take the expert
categories that are generated through
frenzy by the program committee members
and then we couple it with tf-idf to
produce a short list of similar papers
for authors so they don't have to scan
through hundreds of papers to find
what's relevant and in studies what we
found is that having this kind of human
expert input with the machine input
coupled gives you much better
suggestions than if you just do tf-idf
by yourself and then we continue the
chain by taking about 10,000 data points
we get from the authors as see data into
our collaborative filtering algorithm
and what you get then is you basically
skip what's called the Coe start problem
right so normally in collaborative
filtering you kind of have to like a
bunch of stuff
before it starts giving you pretty good
recommendations and here you get great
recommendations right off the bat
because not only are you getting it from
authors right it's actually like a
double filter right like you got the
committee members making these good
groupings and then the authors kind of
refined it even further so we give
really good recommendations right off
the bat and then now you have more
authors sorry more attendees
participating and going in there and
liking things that they like because you
know they're just seeing it like oh I
like this I like this and we get more
data for planning as well so moving on
to step two helping the organizers
resolve conflicts with all this data
we've collected we should just feed it
all into a computer hidden optimize
button and get a schedule out right no
it's a terabyte please don't do that
okay and there's many reasons for it I'm
just gonna give you two reasons right
now one is that the problem is still
actually highly under specified right so
we end up collecting about 1020 thousand
data points
turns out that's only a small portion of
the specification of the planning
problem and for the parts that the
Machine doesn't know right it's only
gonna optimize what it knows you hit the
optimize button
and it's easy to get some incoherent
sessions coming back from the optimizer
is that the optimizer has no idea or
incoherent but you don't have the
constraints to know that and this
wouldn't be such a big problem except
that the organizers don't even know
necessarily that these are bad sessions
right because we said the knowledge of
what makes a good session is often
distributed across the community so what
you get is this problem that even
detective fix some of the bad things
that happen it's actually quite
difficult for the organizers to do if
you use this kind of approach the other
thing is that the organizers and the
organizers often have other tacit
knowledge or goals as I'm looking at
Manish because when you're planning
things you're thinking about other goals
that maybe are harder to represent in a
system or just aren't encoded you want
the organizers to still have that
flexibility and control and working with
the schedule so the third core idea then
is we're gonna take this idea of making
a community based makes the initiative
interface that's going to allow to
organize there's a more flexible way of
operating okay so let me show you how
this works so you could go in and you
get this multi-dimensional view of the
schedule right you can look at all these
different view options you could also
look at personas which is something that
Chi was very into for a while or you
could look at all these ways right and
then you go in and these red bars are
showing you conflicts in the schedule
both based on hard conflicts and also
the community input that we collected
and you could propose a move and what
the system is doing is showing you how
many conflicts would be resolved if you
made these moves recommending the ones
in green that make the most resolve
conflicts but it leaves the organizer in
control to make the decision right the
system doesn't just make the swap for
you you're still in control to make
whatever swaps you want okay and by
doing this what ends up happening is
that the organizers can work on the
schedule with a lot of confidence okay
so what I'm showing you here is over
time the red line is the number of
conflicts going down right that's not
surprising right you could go in there
and then you could get the conflicts
going down what's really interesting is
all the activity that happens when the
conflicts aren't really going down much
but the organizers are still improving
the schedule right and the reason they
could do that is that if they go into
the tool and they have a go in mind of
something they want to change they could
make that change and know if they made
that change how would it affect what
community members said how would it
affect the hard cost
right so it gives you a way to really
apply the tacit knowledge the organizers
have while still considering the
community input and the hard constraints
from the system recommendations as well
so we deploy Cobie at Cayenne CCW in
2012-2013 and here the outcomes from
from that those deployments so the first
one is that we have an inclusive process
for planning that involved 1,500 people
in the planning process it reduced
organizers time from a hundred hours
down to five hours for planning just
good and then organizers produce better
schedules by resolving hundreds of
conflicts they didn't even know about
because they had no way to kind of
incorporate the community-based data so
yeah so those were some of the outcomes
from the study and the takeaways here
right I mean again I think some of you
have seen pieces of this work the
takeaways here is that by thinking at
the ecosystem level where do you get
some pretty interesting design insights
so for example we have this
collaborative planning process that
could work across crowds and groups we
have a way to chain contributions across
the ecosystem right where we take one
interaction and then feed the results of
the interaction to make another
interaction go more smoothly and so on
and so forth and then we have this way
to kind of bring together the system the
organizers and the community community
input into one place where we could
actually operate on the preferences of a
community as a whole so before I move on
to my second example any questions on
Coby and community inform planning yeah
please they don't use it with the whole
process they mostly just use the
scheduling tool right now we've been
approached by two of the biggest
conference planning companies who were
just like oh my god like this is the
next generation and conference planning
things and then they offered us money or
if to consult and whatever else and then
we're just like we're faculty we don't
have time so it does get you go back to
question number one
what we ended up doing is we open
sourced our code we shared it with them
we made sure that I can still run by
having you know that version of code and
then we kind of just gave it away really
to the companies and one of the
companies complex they do like the huge
chip OS and the big conferences on there
actually currently incorporating a lot
of the stuff which is nice but like I
don't know I don't know he even called
that tech transfer it's gonna like here
you go but that's kind of the challenge
right it's like you you have to there's
a lot of pieces and you have to maintain
and get these things in you know all the
things that work with all the video
types and all that stuff right so it's
not I don't think they actually
necessarily need all that expertise now
there is something about replicating
across sites where you have to think
about different communities working
differently and things like that and I
think that's a more serious or more
interesting kind of conceptual question
but outside of that it's just time right
so like it does it may be not
intellectually very interesting but you
know if I'm going to choose to do a
start-up I have to make choices across
systems I'm building and that's that's
kind of what happened here
go ahead could you explain a little bit
more on the nice initiative aspect of
the interfaces and I just want to
understand what what do you mean by
mixed initiative yeah so I mean people
talk about it in different ways right
but humans and machines coming in in
different ways right and here what we
saw in that interface is its mix
initiative but such a kind of
interesting right because it's mixed
initiative but you're operating also on
this community data right so it's mixed
initiative in the ways that the
organizer goes in there you know they
look at something the Machine proposes
something and then the organizer still
is in control to think about it and then
the organizer might do something the
Machine shows the update and then so on
and so forth right it's kind of this
collaborative process of working between
the human and the Machine right maybe
the the clearest contrast is put it into
the optimizer hit a button right now
very mix initiative any other questions
great questions back way
okay are we good okay um let me move on
to my second example and just feel free
to stop me any time if things come up
that you're interested in talking about
okay so I like to go back to scaling
research training I'm cultivating in
particular this idea of cultivating
self-directed learners okay so you know
clearly there's been a lot of effort
here on scaling research training what
I'm going to talk about is quite a bit
different particularly around this idea
of self-directed learning and what we
found is that if you really want
students to be self-directed so that
they could do independent research
they're gonna need something that's
commonly known in psychology and
learning sciences as regulation skills
okay and what regulation skills are is
given a complex goal or some goal that
you have what are all the cognitive
metacognitive motivational and emotional
skills you have or you would need to
have to reach that goal right and for
research the required regulation skills
includes things like planning your work
and monitoring your progress and
replanting as needed and then also
seeking help to overcome challenges as
they come up
and students lacking these skills are
confined to route tasks right like
they're kind of given something to do
you know can't self direct or they could
struggle to make progress where you know
they might hit a block and then wait a
week until they meet with their faculty
mentor before it gets resolved okay and
the thing that um you know for me I just
want to point out here beyond the slides
is that regulation skills are actually
really hard to learn a lot of students
struggle with regulation skills okay
I certainly did as a PhD student I you
know I still do to to a large extent but
the flip side of that is sorry to all
the faculty in the room we do a terrible
job of teaching regulation skills right
and often well you find and maybe it's
different here but is that you know
doing research could feel a lot like
just bang your head against the wall and
then like one day you figure it out
right and I know that's not true for
everyone but I see enough of it to think
that there's got to be a better way that
we could get better results with more
students by helping students build these
regulation skills more effectively so to
address this challenge we created a
computational ecosystem that we call
agile research studios that provides a
model for research training within a
learning community
and in this model all the students
regardless of seniority conduct
independent research and receive
authentic research practice by which I
mean the students will go through a
self-directed project cycle where they
set goals themselves they learn they
plan their work they make progress they
reflect on what's been learned and then
they go through this cycle again so the
core idea here for ARS is that as scales
mentor time right or faculty time right
let the thing that I said doesn't
stretch so we've already talked a little
bit about why you know apprenticeship
doesn't work with once you have more
than a handful of students but you might
think why don't we just go with the
hierarchical model right so have the
faculty mentor the PhD students have the
PhD students mentor the undergrads the
challenge here though is that as grad
students are still learning how to do
research they're novice mentors right
there's actually a really big difference
as I've talked about a lot in the
learning sciences between being an
expert at something and being an expert
teacher in that thing so what happens is
that often undergrads working with grad
students are still kind of doing route
tests is not really self directing the
research project so instead what we're
gonna do with this ARS approach is that
we're gonna do take a dispersed control
model where we're gonna distribute
various roles of the faculty member
across the entire community so that we
could overcome what's commonly known as
the 1x challenge right so one faculty
responding to many students like I had
to do at lunch got you guys okay
what ARS is it's a computational
ecosystem for developing regulation
skills okay so it's got processes social
structures and tools right so we use
agile processes and we adapt agile
processes from software development and
design to research to scaffold the
self-directed learning cycle mentoring
is distributed across all these
different social structures to support
student learning how to plan research
work and get help within a supportive
community and that we have these virtual
studio tools that support learning
through this agile process and that
promotes effective interactions within
the community okay so I'm not gonna
present the whole model to you guys but
I'm gonna give you a couple of vertical
slices to help build intuition so first
I'd like to talk a bit about a student
learning to plan research work
so we adapt the agile process from
software development as I was saying and
as students are gonna plan their work at
two-week intervals where the goal is to
deliver value but not user value as you
might be familiar with an agile but to
deliver research value okay and that's
something I'm happy to get into a longer
discussion about and how we train data
how we think about that but think about
like what's the most you can learn about
your research project in a two-week
period and as they do this we have these
sig meetings
okay so sig meetings is where in a
one-hour period we have about two to
three student teams who are working on
different projects but in the same
research area roughly right you can
think about it as one NSF grant if you
like and then you have a faculty mentor
who fades out over time as a graduate
student mentor who is in desig learns to
lead their own sake so for example my
PhD students by the time they graduate
would have mentored about five to eight
projects and 10 to 15 students and
they're effectively running their own
research lab before they graduate from
their PhD and what happens in this
meeting is that we're giving the
students feedback on their plants right
so students come in with a plan and then
we're asking them questions like well
okay so why do this instead of this like
what are other options you could
consider are you gonna have enough
points or hours to do this is there a
different way to prototype you could
think about that might give you the same
learning but with actually that can
actually fit within two weeks okay so
we're starting to develop these
regulation skills and planning in these
meetings to support this process for
students recording their stuff and for
sharing that with both their peers and
mentors we have a sprint log the sprint
log is a lot like project tracking tools
with two differences so one difference
is that it has these questions to help
students think about planning right and
it's actually teaching planning with
some of these prompts all right and this
is something that's often missing and
the professional tools because they
they're not thinking about a learning
teaching setting the other thing as I
mentioned a little bit during lunch is
that we actually cap the number of hours
our point students are allowed to put on
their sprint right so we actually say
for undergrads um you can't go over
eight points a week or sixteen points a
spread and the idea there is I don't
want my students to overwork I want them
to learn how to work within these
constraints to be as effective as
Hampi okay so the goal is not to just
over work so here's a picture of a
sprint meeting so I have my student
bomani who is presenting right and then
leashes the sick head and then all these
other students are working on different
projects kind of giving him feedback and
seeing what he's talking about and then
that's my dog Stella who's mostly there
just to get petted but she's also there
for moral support and all kinds of other
stuff belly rubs okay so let me move on
and give you a different vertical slice
of the problem where we're gonna talk
about helping collaboration and the core
idea here is that we're gonna distribute
help across the entire community so one
of the ways we do that is we gather for
a three-hour studio meeting every week
where during that meeting people engage
in peer help we do demo and critique we
also do some instruction through
learning modules where we're teaching
students how to think about making
arguments do study design like kind of
the skills that you would need to be an
effective researcher and to think to
have a conceptual model of what it means
to do research and then one of the tools
we use in the studio is called peer
research okay what peer research does is
it pairs students up to help each other
right a faculty as well so let me just
show you pair research real quickly we
recently built this pair research
platform where you could go in and you
could put in I need help finalizing this
for me right the intro to my talk and
other people are putting in what they
need help with and then I'm reading how
well I could help each person write I
could really help those people and that
is much here right really help on those
things right and other people are
filling this in as well and then you go
back up you can make pairs confetti
falls from the sky trust me I was like
we have that and we have a horserace
here too I'm gonna talk about that later
if it's like this is why we love this
tool um alright and then it makes pairs
okay and what the pairs are doing is
that it's computing the global maximum
weighted matching across the community
where people can best help each other
and one way to think about that is that
like for me for example for me as a
faculty member there's a student who no
other students can help it's likely that
student will get paired with me if I
could actually help that student and
what it's doing then it's maximally
using the distributed expertise within
your community as you're building up the
capacity of each student to respond to
challenges okay now just as a minor
minor
sigh point we actually purposely don't
make perfect pairings
well actually perturb it a little bit
just a little bit okay where if you
paired recently you're less likely to
get paired again and the idea is that we
try to get more different pairings so
the skills distribute across the network
a lot more quickly so that's just a
little perturbation we put into the
system so one thing that I want to note
though before you know everyone goes Oh
pair research is shiny and it's awesome
is that hair research is great and
you'll get benefits using it on its own
but the student help is not a single app
instead it's a helping culture that
results from having a whole ecosystem
around help ok so what you're seeing on
the left is students kind of learning
over the shoulder in the lab and hanging
out in the lab and learning from each
other getting help I'll slack we have
all these channels for getting help in
different areas where people might need
help on the upper right my students
started their own onboarding program for
new students they just started it where
for onboarding there's a lot of to learn
and then they have these weekly
check-ins with with other students and
then as I was mentioning for sig
meetings in that meeting students often
also identify or discuss how to overcome
their blockers right so if they hit a
bug they're thinking about who could
help them both in pair research my house
Ida pair research and it's a lot of meet
up outside of in-person meetings that
are structured or scheduled and online
as well okay and then on the bottom what
I'm showing you is a small slice of our
reflection practice so every ten weeks
or every quarter my students do a ten
page self-assessment where they're
reflecting on their learning process and
what this question is asking about is
just about teamwork and collaboration as
students are thinking about how they
could be more effective in giving and
getting help for the needs that they
have so let me just show you some of the
high-level outcomes from this program in
the first three years of the program
I've mentored 50 students and mostly
undergraduates in independent research
across 25 research projects and the
students want 29 undergraduate research
grants from the University and that's
I'm 100% sure it's the most within the
last 10 years but I'm pretty sure it
might be in the most like ever that
people have have earned and the students
published 11 papers and extended
abstracts at conferences like Chi and
West
and then we have for student research
competition winners most recently Salem
who just won the high student research
competition so 96% of students stay in
the program for at least two quarters
but really most meaning almost all
continue until they graduate many of
them enter even as sophomores and they
just stay in the program until until
they graduate so for quite some time so
the outcomes are really great to see but
one of the things I'm really excited
about is seeing evidence that students
are starting to develop these regulation
skills so we see students reporting
developing all these different planning
strategies for example building at the
fidelity appropriate for the current
stage of the research prioritizing
important features sequencing tasks and
then in some cases moving on despite a
certainty because you do that sometimes
and we also found that students were
helping each other a lot and they were
developing in their help-seeking
disposition okay so the first date I
want to share is that students helped
more than a third of their studio every
quarter okay and the second is that over
the second second quote I have here is
just some evidence right that students
are developing help-seeking disposition
so one student says I can ask for help
and that everyone asks for help and it
doesn't make them stupid to need help
and you might think this is really silly
it's like who cares
but help-seeking is really difficult
right a lot of students struggle with
getting help when they need it and just
to see any evidence that they're
starting to develop these kinds of
dispositions this is really encouraging
to see and when showing you on the Ray
is from winter 2016 where each note is a
student and each color is a sig and what
you see is a densely connected graph
where people are helping each other in
the same sig but they're also helping
each other unlock across legs as well so
coming back to that not stretchable part
at the faculty time it now takes me 10
to 12 hours a week to run this community
okay and to operate on my research so
five hours spent on sig meetings is that
you a little less now because one of my
graduate students effectively kicked me
out of the sig meetings actually kicked
myself out because just just he's ready
like he's ready to lead his own sake he
doesn't need me there so so that's a
little lower and then there's three
hours for the studio meeting and I do
normally about two hours of impersonal
help their office hours and then two
hours to respond online or for impromptu
stuff that comes up okay and then before
we had this model when I had about a
dozen students I was up till 2:00 in the
morning just about every other day I'm
kind of trying to go one Oh
all the students so so my life is a lot
better now there's some caveat so for
the week before the keidel I my life is
not as good just like oh yours alright
so there's some parts that we haven't
quite scaled yeah in terms of faculty
time although we do actually have some
ideas there that I'm happy to talk about
afterwards if you're interested so the
two core things that we're seeing here
with this computational ecosystem
fragile Research Studios um the first is
that we're helping to develop regulation
skills for research planning and help
seeking by using all these different
ecosystem interactions across all these
people and social groups um and what's
interesting to me is that we're starting
to extend the scale and the capacity of
a community to produce research work but
also to learn right and in a way where a
single faculty mentor could have never
done it but in an ecosystem you can and
to me that's just really interesting to
think about how the system is doing
something that we couldn't have imagined
otherwise and one of the questions that
were really interested in exploring in
future work is how do the students
developing these regulation skills help
them outside of the studio that they're
in for me training students in with this
model in Aris with the ARS model is
rewarding you know partly because
students are learning how to do research
but for me really it's because of what
regulation skills can do for students
once they're away from from the program
right that if they have the regulation
skills to approach challenges that they
find deeply rewarding and the skills to
think about how to self-direct their own
learning to work on those things um
that's the thing that I'm most excited
about and that's actually the reason I
want to scale this right that's one of
the big values that I have for this and
in future work that's the thing that I'm
really interested in studying is beyond
school what are these regulation skills
doing for for these students so before I
move on to the the latter parts of my
talk any questions about agile research
guess I like you like surely like you've
gotten like there's feedback so I'm like
like what's keeping people like awake
like what is what is keeping them
returning it's actually a hard question
I'll say what I think it is and I've
actually think we want to do some more
detail studies to really understand
why that's happening so what a which is
as you saw from a lot of this it's
really centered around personal growth
right it's not just like project through
the project to the project it's like how
are you growing as a person and my
students are coming back after enough
over and over again because they're
realizing what this practice is doing
for their regulation skills and personal
growth right in addition to anything for
their project now they also like their
project to keep working on it and so on
the other thing is is this it's the
community these students they don't just
do research together right on their
individual projects they hang out
together they take classes together they
really bond over this community and a
lot of the programs this gets to the
adaptation question you're asking
earlier where a lot of things you know
the students are thinking about how to
improve this community they're very
invested in making it better okay and be
really nice to understand all those
facets with more detail study but yes as
I mentioned during lunch at the end of
the day not the end of the day at the
beginning of the day when students enter
the program they choose we don't choose
for them they have to choose and
sometimes it counts down to two choices
and they say just choose for me and I
say no uterus right so they take
ownership the second nature's yeah are
there questions okay great so let me let
me move on a little bit um and then I
don't to just talk a little bit about
what's next as a preview and how we're
advancing the kind of system level
thinking that's embedded in these
examples that I just showed you kind of
thinking about that in broader terms
okay so the first preview I want to talk
about is thinking about ecosystem level
architectures and what I mean by that is
thinking about what are ways to kind of
coordinate activities across the entire
ecosystem and really thinking at an
architectural level how we might be able
to support the members of the ecosystem
and also the ecosystem functioning
properly so let me just give you one
example of this we've been working on
this area of research that I call on the
go crowdsourcing where the idea is to
motivate large numbers of people to
contribute to solving local communal
problems but through their existing
routine
so what I'm showing you here is someone
who went to the package center who got a
notification to say would you be willing
to pick up some packages for other
people in your dorm and she said yes I
guess to three of them okay and then
she's bringing it back to the dorm and
what I'm interested in here you know one
is kind of alternative model for
thinking about tasking than the kind of
uber a pure economy model but it's also
a way to think about how to connect
communities kind of building these kinds
of social capital through these small
tasks that are conveniently in people's
routines and that's kind of the value I
care about here but a court challenge in
trying to enable these kinds of systems
is the need to balance what the system
needs to get done and the conveniens and
other goals of the individuals right and
there may be many tasks in many
different regions if you're thinking
about time banking or in our case we
were doing the lost-and-found thing
where we had a lost item and then people
were searching for lost items for just
30 seconds along their route in
different regions and it'd be incredible
right if what you could do is people
just walk around opportunistically and
they get a ping just somewhere by
determined by the system but you get
globally effective outcomes right and
that's what we started to do with this
mechanism that we call hidden weight a
hitter way and what hitter weight is
doing this is my PhD student yellow
cells work is if you have these
different regions where the tests are of
different importance or value right so
region two is really important someone
comes over and starts walking to the
right and they're approaching the region
through yang you might say well you know
what maybe I should wait right like I
should wait because you know there's a
good chance the person might reach
region two okay but if they happen to
reach region two then you might hit
right and you would decide to give them
the test then and what the system is
doing in the back end it's use it's
using decision theory to kind of compute
these things in real time
opportunistically as people are coming
in and in notifying them where the
system needs are but conveniently along
people's routes right so I think just
think thinking about the ecosystem and
connecting people in this way in ways
that balance individual convenience and
also these kind of global outcomes
really exciting and how these ways of
thinking you know typically for
optimization use decision theory can
actually enable new forms of interaction
and ways of communicating community
members so in another direction for my
second preview
we're starting to think more deeply
about Mick's initiative but Mick's
initiative with humans and machines
across the ecosystem okay so let me just
give you an example of this that I'm
thinking about where we've been working
on this area called readily available
learning experiences where the idea is
that you could take any real world
artifact in our case websites but any
website and you could play with it and
interact with their say I want to learn
how that happened right I want to build
a conceptual model in my head so I know
how to create that how did that actually
work I know on something like tumblr if
you've been on tumblr you see a
scrolling effect it's like the smoothest
thing ever it's like how do they do that
and I want to learn how to do that
scrolling effect and this is a problem
that people have thought about how to
extract relevant code there's been a lot
of work in that in in the whist
community but it's much harder to build
a system that can automatically scaffold
the process of building a conceptual
model for the learner okay so let me
just show you how we're starting to do
that with a system called iso plan um so
this was worked from my PhD student Josh
and we're looking at a New York City
skyline article from National Geographic
that's super cool right I'm just like it
looks really cool and what we're showing
here is a condensed car graph on the
bottom and then there's these aspect
filters on top where you could look at
all the stuff that had to do with Ajax
or all the stuff that was tracing across
from the mouse events and as you're
looking at this and exploring different
parts you could go in and define your
own custom aspects for a code that
happened after a certain time stamp or
whatever you want to put in and you're
now looking at those codes and you're
putting in positive and negative filters
as you're looking at okay well how do i
how do I look at this which are parts
that might be interested in and you
might go in and click one of these as
you're doing since making and we're
showing you these asynchronous bindings
in the purple lion so we actually get
the asynchronous bindings for JavaScript
because normally you never know why that
function was called in JavaScript okay I
mean you could go ahead and label things
as your understanding pieces and it's
like putting together a puzzle where
you're doing this iterative sense making
process to understand oh that's what
this is doing okay and then what does
that do so you start understanding how
the pieces of code and components
coordinate to make for the whole and to
me that's a wonderful start and really
exciting already but we're at you're
going to take
leap where instead of just thinking
about makes initiative tools we're
starting to develop makes initiative
scaffolds that go across the ecosystem
and let me explain what I mean by that
so you have the tool that we use for
building conceptual models but once you
have it how do you build scaffolding
exercises that you could just give to
people to practice on so what we do is
we take the labels that people generated
in the process of learning and would use
that with an automated method to
scaffold the next piece of learning
where the student can now do something
else and then we could take that data
and then do something else with it to
get this closed loop kind of process for
thinking about doing self-directed
learning on these complex examples that
you know the intelligent tutors are not
going to do this anytime soon right but
somehow with this mix initiative
approach across these different
components we might actually be able to
get there okay so we're just starting
some of this work and I think it's
really promising to think about what
this might look like so I want to end my
talk by spending just a few minutes
talking about the role of Technology in
advancing human values at scale okay and
I want to start this discussion with a
cup of clear caveats okay the first two
switch first the which is that much has
been already said about human values
right I mean you should go look at stuff
in philosophy in Psychology and wherever
you find your values from and in HCI I'm
looking at some about your free minutes
work is really good that's what I would
recommend okay so I'm not gonna rehash
any of that and further people don't
share the same values right so I'm not
trying to say okay we're gonna design
just for this value or that value and
instead what I want to talk about is
this idea of scaling with technology how
that interfaces with our values and in
particular the point I'm making is that
scaling amplifies that kind of
compromises we might make when we start
scaling with technology so this is a
short story from 1909 that I highly
highly recommend everyone read called
the Machine stops okay and trim by a guy
named Ian Foster and he's talking about
a world or he's writing this in 1909
that has augmented reality the Internet
and social media 1909 right but on one
hand it sounds a lot like the technology
technological golden age of today but
the story wasn't really about that it's
actually about what we given up about
ourselves when we
settings that's good enough so that the
machine may progress the machine may
progress the machine may progress to
Eternity um and there's this part of the
story very early in this short story
from the boy and there's just a boy and
his mother the two characters or the
boys trying to get his mother to come
visit him as she wouldn't because she's
like what's the point I could just see
you on this plate right that's that was
their screen and then he says to her the
machine is much but it's not everything
I see something like you in this plate
but I do not see you I hear something
like you through this telephone but I do
not hear you that is why I want you to
come pay me a visit so that we can meet
face-to-face and talk about the hopes
that are in my mind so every time I read
this I find it heart warming at
heartbreaking at the same time and you
know so we are creating incredible
machines at scale to do incredible
things but you know this is an example
of a simple thing that we might have
missed when we scale and the question I
have for you is the following okay for
the values that you wish the scale the
values you care about personally what
are those values and then what is it
that you have technological solutions
for with with regards to your values and
if they're fully aligned great okay
you're doing great but if they're not
what do you do and one of the things I'm
really worried about and deeply scared
about is how we could just say no you
know what those are not my values I'm
just going to adopt my values to be
these technological values of what I
could scale with technology and instead
what I hope everyone to be able to do is
to say no no these are the values that
character scale I don't know how to do
them with technology only or I just
don't know how to do it but that's the
problem we should be working on and I
think if we all worked on problems that
we cared about it doesn't have to be my
values and we try to think about how to
do it even when the technology is in
there I think that'd be a really
wonderful thing but to do that it's
going to require that we're mindful of
our values what we care about we have to
think about reaching beyond the limits
of what technology is giving us and
furthermore we have to learn to scale I
mean I really emphasize the word learned
there we're scaling is not just more
servers or more people
right as I shown you in this example
scaling is quite complicated we have to
be humble as we think about learning to
scale the things that we care about and
we need to build new knowledge and new
ways of thinking and I think
computational ecosystems is giving you a
slice of that and it's an important step
in that direction
because if it's about humans that
thinking about ourselves it's a part of
a larger ecology is going to be
important and if it's going to be these
complex problems they're having
computational thinking to bring in our
human and machine ingenuities and put
them together is going to be important
as well so with your help I hope what we
can do is to start bridging the ways we
embrace design and technologies power
with our deepest needs as as humans so
with that I like to thank my wonderful
collaborators on the COBE project for
their work on communion film planning
and I just my students are incredible my
students in DT are and have the PhD
students bolded on the top and then my
faculty wonderful faculty collaborators
in red on the bottom and just lastly the
Delta lab where I'm one of the
co-directors with Liz Garber I'm at
Easter day Nell Rourke and myself you
know liz is a designer and
organizational behavior most matsa
learning scientists now is a cs+
learning science person right now I'm I
mean so the the way we're able to do
work is there's no blinders like I could
do stuff that I want to do that aligned
with my values but I could never do that
without learning all these things that
I'm learning from them on a daily basis
and from their students and our students
as well and I think Stanford's a
wonderful place to do research and to be
engineer but if you're done or when
you're done with Stanford and you're
graduated or whatnot well we are looking
for students postdocs fellows and
developers okay so thank you guys so
much and thanks for being a wonderful
yes
[Applause]
please what we're here I'll use an
appropriate project yeah so um it's what
I said I said setting briefly on the
first slide but it's heavy inclusive
process where a community can actually
advance the goals of all its members and
there's you know various literature's
that inform that kind of values but
great question okay I I want to be
respectful I don't want the sort of
trailing out that's that's rude to the
speaker so thanks how she will be here
as soon as we could finish clapping so
please bring your question out with Kara
Winston you too and thank you
[Applause]
you